this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so we all know we all try to
read to maintain a healthy and diverse
diet but this is not always easy
although many although the nutrient
deficiencies are less common in
developed nations surprisingly high
proportions of the u.s. population still
do not obtain the daily amount
recommended for several nutrients
including vitamin E so what if I tell
you that we could help with that by
increasing the nutritional quality of
sweet corn which I bet many of you I so
my project my project is trying to
understand the mechanism of vitamin
accumulation in order to convert the
locally adapted corn lines into a dark
yellow grain with high provitamin a and
vitamin E so curtain eyes are compounds
produced by plants and some of them are
pro vitamin A why Oracle criminals are
vitamin E so there are several compounds
within each class so from now on I'm
going to be using the colors orange and
green to distinguish between them as
antioxidants they might decrease the
risk of several health complications
including cardiovascular disease
age-related macular degeneration which
can cause blindness and specific cancers
I study showed that about 26 to 26 to 41
percent of u.s. population has low
levels of vitamin E and this may be
associated with increases risk of
cardiovascular disease also
age-related macular degeneration affects
about 25% of people of 65 years old and
older and northeast is the region with
the highest proportion of people over
that age so this
this demonstrate the importance of
studies to increase the vitamin in the
food crop so sweet corn because it's a
it's widely consumed this could be a
good candidate for biofortification
which is the increasing nutrition
nutritional priority of food crops for
by breeding sweet corn is the third most
we consume vegetable in the US it is
estimated that each person is about 11
kilograms of sweet corn high year and
New York is one of the most important
state it is among the the top five
states in production production and
value of fresh sweet corn and also it
has is it is the second state with the
highest number of fresh market and this
is a great opportunity for address
common dietary deficiency biosynthetic
biosynthetic pathways for these
compounds are well endures characterized
from here the main idea to remember are
the alpha and beta carotene as well as
beta crystals ending I provided in a
lutein and zeaxanthin are associated
with reduces risk of age-related macular
degeneration and alpha tocopherol has
highest highest the highest vitamin E
activity also the enzyme denoted by the
stars were were previously reported to
be associated with increase of this or
some of these compounds and this
information could be used to improve
sweet corn as well however when you
consider when you look at the genetic
distance of sweet corn to the all the
few a few corn you can see that sweet
corn is a distant breeding pool and it
has also less variability also the new
to treat the nutrient analogies of sweet
corn
needs to be done during the fresh stage
which is when it when sweet corn is
didn't as a vegetable so our main
question here is are the genes
responsible for increasing vitamins the
same at both stage and are the favor
alleles found in few corn as present in
our panel so my the goal for my project
is to understand the mechanism of the
nutritional quality additional trading
fresh sweet corn kernels in order to
achieve that we're trying to identify
correlated genes and favor alleles and
develop and validate marker based of the
prediction models in order just as the
birth of natural variation for this
compound we use it a penny with four
hundred inbred lines from public reading
from public breeding programs across the
u.s. we planted it two years and then we
harvest at eating stage which is about
21 days after pollination so the years
were then fresh frozen shelled and they
were later ground and kept in a - daily
freezer and the curtain identical
criminals were a measure using HPLC
using these phenotypes together with
genotypes from GBS we performed a
genome-wide Association study and then
for alpha tocopherol which is the
compound with greatest vitamin D
activity we we found a significant
association with markers in chromosome 5
which is close to this gene with BT 4
which is located encodes an enzyme
located at the end of the pathway right
before the compound and this candidate
gene was previously reported in field
corn as well also for delta 2 gamma
tocotrienols ignition key in chromosome
5 however this markers are close to VT 1
which as you can see here in encodes
enzymes they are in both branches that
goes to the compound when looking at
genetic correlation between the
compounds we can see that some of them
are highly correlated which is shown by
the darker orange in this case we could
use the extra information to provide
provided by the cross-strait correlation
in a multivariate G was in order to
increase the power to identify
associations and also a joint analysis
will be more consistent with the biology
when the a single variant is associated
with multiple trait so we did the same
analysis by using multivariate G was and
instead of using the ratio of the two
compounds we are using both together and
then after controlling for Colonel type
we still get the v t-1 the same kita i
mentioned before but we also have a new
association with with this gene that is
enclosed in enzyme like from the
precursors and this was not previously
reported for toko criminals and this
also makes sense because since if you
think like by having a favored a leo
here you can increase the substrate for
the downstream compounds so in summary
this we identify genes
candidate genes three candidate genes as
I mentioned and being this one a new
Association these are for all four Toco
Toco criminals and we also found one
Association for carotenoids but I just
would like to mention that carotenoids
we only have one data so one year of
data so far while criminals we have the
two years already and then we we now
expect to identify the best variants
within those regions and use that to
select the best performing line lines to
be used as a fairing
we also use genomic prediction using
genome-wide markers to calculate
breeding values for each of those traits
we use it a ridge regression blood and
then by doing five fold cross validation
we got accuracies as high as point six
one for this compound or provide them in
a I had accuracy 0.4 and vitamin e point
35 for example so this line the lines of
the highest breeding values for
complimentary traits such as so we chose
traits with high vitamin E and high
vitam providing a for example and then
we cross them last year and this is
generated from that we are going to be
planting this coming season to start
validating the models and to start the
breeding population
so in summary we found different sheets
for for eat for some of the compounds
the in this one a new Association we
already start making the cost is last
year and then this is the first step to
to start increasing the vitamins in
sweet corn going from white with low
vitamin A for example and to dark yellow
lines with more Pro vitamin A and hope
and hopefully provide emini as well
I'd like to thank everybody they helped
with my project especially my the gore
lab thank you for your attention and I
will happy to answer any questions you
may have
[Applause]
here there are different colors of
available evidence
so we have I don't I don't have a right
answer for that because it's pretty
subjective but I what I understand is
that if you start telling people that
that's going to be make them better like
it's better because that's more vitamins
and in theory you shouldn't change
anything else like the taste we are
trying to still make good lines so they
should I think they should they would be
willing to change and even though if
they prefer like white white sweet corn
I I believe they would change for if
it's better for their health how much
the very end of the huge things that are
changing that went over exactly
so that was in the past for few corny
what sound like was a really high effect
and then we didn't find as high as the
so I don't think we have as many
variation as the few corn but is still
like we have really big hits for those
jeans so it's they are still controlling
most of the variation
yes I was going on about how much of
your very in your button earrings
okay normal question on this doesn't go
the virtual this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu